The Miami Dolphins are a
team extremely rich in history.
The Chicago Bears are one
of the two oldest teams who
are still playing in the NFL.
In my opinion, any
time the Eagles lose,
that's a good thing.
RICK HARRISON: Earlier, a
guy brought in some playbooks
from the 1966 Miami Dolphins.
It's an awesome piece
of football history.
But it's so unique, I really
don't know how to price it.
So I asked my guy Jeremy to
come down and help me out.
The Miami Dolphins are a
team extremely rich in history.
And to see a playbook
from their days
when they joined the
AFL is really cool.
It was guys like Bob
Griese, Larry Csonka,
and legendary coach,
Don Shula, who
has won more than any
other coach in the history
of the NFL, and went on to
accomplish what no other team
has accomplished before,
the perfect season, which
they did in 1972.
Playbooks themselves, they
date back over 100 years.
And in a sense, they contain
all of the team's secrets.
It's literally like
learning another language
between all the blocking
assignments, and
different routes, and packages.
What is something
like this worth?
I mean, is there even
a market for this?
Itinerary and all, you're
looking at about $400.
RICK HARRISON: Thanks
man you're the best.
You bet, Rick.
RICK HARRISON: So how
much do you want for them?
How about $275?
How about $200?
CUSTOMER: How about $270?
Oh, yeah, you're
really going down.
Well, they're probably
worth more now than they
were when they were printed.
No, no, when
they were printed,
they were probably worth a
lot of money to somebody.
[laughter]
I guess you have
a point there.
I'll tell you what,
I'll give you $250.
And I don't even know
why I'm going that high.
$260?
$250.
They are going to
sit for a while.
That's a deal.
All right.
All right Man, let's go
do some paperwork, buddy.
COREY HARRISON:
Earlier a guy came
in with a football signed by a
bunch of the '67 Chicago Bears.
Before I can make
an offer, I've got
to make sure these
signatures are legit.
So I called in Jeremy
to help me out.
The Chicago Bears are one
of the two oldest teams who
are still playing in the NFL,
and as far as fan bases go,
they have one of the most
loyal fan bases of any team
out there.
What concerns you have?
There's a lot of
signatures on this ball.
Plus, I don't know what to
price it as because they're
relatively famous players.
Absolutely.
And as we all know, Brian
Piccolo isn't around anymore.
Now, if we were dealing
with an official ball, mint
condition signatures,
we'd be talking
several thousand dollars.
Now, I'm looking at
some of the signatures.
We have to determine
whether or not
these are even authentic ones.
Those signatures, they are
100% spot on exactly what
I want to see in a 1967 ball.
Now, the other
signatures, you've
really got to focus
on the characteristics
of the autograph.
If you compare the Brian
Piccolo signature here
to the one on the
football, these
are contrasting signatures,
very typical for what you
see in a clubhouse signature.
They were signed by somebody
else other than the athlete.
The Sayers, like the
Piccolo, in my opinion,
these are clubhouse autographs.
Considering the
kind of ball it's
on, which ones are real versus
which are in the clubhouse,
you're looking at
maybe tops $1,000.
COREY HARRISON: Jeremy, man,
I appreciate you coming in.
Any time, Corey.
All right, see ya later.
All right, man,
so you heard my guy.
He says, it's worth
probably around $1,000.
I mean, I've got
a feeling this is
going to sit around for years.
I'd offer you
around $100 for it.
I'll just keep
holding on to it.
Right on, man, appreciate it.
RICK HARRISON: Earlier a guy
brought in a 2004 New England
Patriots Super Bowl ring.
But the manufacturer's
mark doesn't look right.
So I called in my buddy who's
an expert to take a look.
Super Bowl 39, this is
the Super Bowl where
they beat the Eagles 24-21.
And in my opinion, any
time the Eagles lose,
that's a good thing.
[laughter]
What I know of Ricky
Bryant, he actually
pretty much was on the practice
squad for most of the season.
RICK HARRISON: But
he was a player.
Right.
Even guys in the practice
squad do get rings.
At this point, this
ring was the heaviest,
and it was the most expensive
ring that they had ever
made for any Super Bowl game.
It's cast in 14k white gold.
It's got 124 diamonds, and
also, it says three out of four.
Unfortunately, anytime you
have a high profile item,
counterfeiters figure
out creative ways
to pass off fakes.
OK, I see we've got Jostens.
Usually you would
see that in not only
in a different
location, but it looks
to be actually hand
engraved rather than
actually out of the machine.
But this thing was so enormous,
it didn't fit inside Jostens'
normal ring engraver.
They actually had to have
somebody laser engrave each
and every ring as you see here.
So this ring is 100% legit.
And it's pretty awesome.
Sweet.
So what do you think it's worth?
Super Bowl rings from
players such as this sell
from about $30,000 to $35,000.
Nice, nice.
Thanks, man, you're the best.
You bet.
RICK HARRISON: So how much
do you want for this thing?
$22,000.
$18,000.
I'd go $21,000.
- I'll give you $20,000.
- Pass.
20 grand-- cash.
If you'd go $20,000
you'd go $21,000.
- Deal.
COREY HARRISON: All
right, write him up, Chum.